hey everyone it's mike from overflows
and welcome to the special presentation
on the order flows a sequencing
indicator for ninjatrader 8. you know
before we begin just understand that
trading does involve risk and you should
only trade with money that is
set aside for trading now many traders
don't realize that the different types
of traders that exist in the two-way
auction oftentimes they think that the
market is simply made up of buyers and
sellers and while there are buyers and
sellers in the market you know it's just
not
um as simple as
it seems on the surface and let me
explain
within the world of buyers and sellers
there are different types of buyers and
sellers there are aggressive traders
which are the aggressive buyers and the
aggressive sellers there are passive
traders which are the passive buyers and
passive sellers and if you've ever
looked at the dome the depth of market
you'll notice that there are bids and
there's offers okay and there's
differences within that so
remember the market trades in a two-way
auction so here we have a market that's
45 19 75 bid offered at 45 20. the 30
contracts that are on the bid here these
are passive buyers the 36 that are below
at 45 19 and a half are passive buyers
the 54 sitting on the bid at 19 and a
quarter are passive buyers
the
lots that are offered at 45 20 these are
passive sellers the 56 at 20 and a
quarter our passive sellers the 71 at 50
and uh sorry at 20 and a half our
passive sellers and so on now for a
trade to occur
someone has to cross this bid offer line
if
everybody that wants to buy is only
willing to pay 19 and three quarters
they're not willing to pay 20 no trade
will happen just as if no seller
wants to sell below 45.20 no trade will
happen so someone has to cross the bid
offer line either an aggressive buyer
has to buy from the passive seller
that would be an aggressive buyer okay
now if someone
crossed the bid offer and sold at 45 19
and three quarters that would be
considered an aggressive seller so you
have passive buyers that work the bid
and below you have aggressive sellers
that sell into the bids
you have passive sellers that are
working offers
and you have aggressive buyers that buy
from the passive sellers now i'm sure
we've all seen the time and sales and
you know
nowadays the way the markets are there's
they move very fast and it's very
confusing if you're trying to watch the
time in sales because honestly you're
not going to make anything of it you can
see here there's all these trades um
this is at 9 16 and 18 9
16 and 18 seconds here it starts down at
the bottom up here at the top is still
the same one second you're seeing all
these trades go through
okay so it's moving super fast now if
you've ever wondered what the different
colors are well that denotes the type of
trading that was going on if it was
aggressive selling or aggressive buying
all right so
there's information in the time and
sales but the problem is it just moves
too fast and
you know on a dome you can sort of
get a sense of what's happening in the
market but the problem is
you really want to keep track of what's
happening
in the actual trading now the bids and
offers that you see on the dome are just
levels that people are willing to buy at
or levels people are willing to sell at
and
it doesn't always the market doesn't
always trade to those levels sometimes
you see big orders get in going in and
getting pulled before the market trades
there sometimes um you know
not so much nowadays but in the past you
know people love to play games with
putting in size and pulling it etc but
looking at a dome doesn't really give
you
an accurate
indication of
what's happening in the market okay
time and sales which is the actual trade
recap of what happened in the market is
going to be more useful because you can
see the
volume
that traded
at price and whether it was traded
aggressively okay
whether meaning it was aggressively
bought or aggressively sold and you know
this sort of comes into the next segment
on
order types right because again you see
these orders going in getting pulled
trading etc
but big orders right the orders that
have an effect on the market and who
works the big orders you know the big
traders the institutions the
um you know the banks the hedge funds
the the ctas you know the
the hedgers etc
they have big orders to work you know
and this is e-minis and if you've got to
buy a thousand e-minis well there's not
enough liquidity in here okay you're
going to move the market one way or the
other especially if you'd plop in a
thousand lot order jumping on the bid or
work an offer it's gonna
you know have an immediate near-term
effect on the market might scare some
people away or it might attract
you know the opposite side
and
nowadays there are you know banks
the prime banks which are prime brokers
now for you know the hedge funds and and
institutions
they
have their own suite of execution algos
i mean there's a whole
what do you want to call it you know and
i've been saying this for years there's
an arms race among um banks
to offer the best execution algos
because there is what they call
execution alpha um you know if you are a
big fund
it doesn't have to be a big fund but if
you know your orders are
you know 100 lots and up each time you
know a simple
thing as a half of a tick
improvement on a fill
over the course of a year is going to
you know help your bottom line right you
want to try and beat
um you know the existing bid offer
that's in the market and how do they do
that well they have these different
execution algos
um i'm just going to
do a brief summary on them i mean it's
fascinating if
you know you ever get a chance to sit
down with somebody that has worked at a
bank and you know you just sort of talk
about these things if you're into that
but
there's liquidity seeking algorithms
okay now these aren't there to try and
um
you know
pull tricks on the market etc they're
there to fill orders
so these these algorithms they're there
they're created because you know
big um you know big traders have big
orders that they need filled without
impacting the market and
you know the first part that i'll talk
about is what they call liquidity
seeking algorithms right and it takes
the available liquidity without showing
the order to the market right you don't
want to just show the everywhere every
trader out there
basically what you're trying to do okay
you want to hide it in some way you know
and
in the old days
um you know hedge funds you know had
their own broke had brokers that they
like to use because the guys on the
trading desk knew how to fill the orders
without impacting the markets now um
it's all computerized okay and what
these liquidity seeking algorithms do is
you know they they keep track of the
fair price and they wait for
replenishments at that fair price while
continuously
computer computing the dynamic fair
price okay and so what what's going on
is
you know the
algorithm is is deciding while the
market is you know
bit offered you know is this a fair
price it'll keep working a bit if it
thinks you know the fair price is moving
it'll probably start lifting the offer
there's there's all many different ways
that it that it works it's okay
and what it's going to do is it's going
to keep crossing that spread the bid
offer as long as it's the fair price
still if the fair price starts moving
it's going to get aggressive right and
it's going to start crossing the bid
offer
line and then clear that out and
potentially work a new bid at what was
the offer right and start trading
against the new offer it's going to keep
the
what do you want to call it
you know it's going to keep the
order working
as long as it's getting a fair price in
the market okay now another algo
that is fairly common is is the pov algo
the percentage of volume and that allows
you to trade large orders with minimal
market impact right basically you know
what you want to do if you have a big
order is you want to
participate
in the trading that's going on so it's
going to work passive orders trying to
get better executions but as soon as the
filled quantity falls behind
the pov algo becomes aggressive and
catches the spread to
um catch up on the order so again you
know if it's working a bit but moore's
trading on the offer it starts getting
aggressive starts trading more on the
offer it's participating at each price
that's trading basically is what a
percentage of volume is you know you set
it to whatever 20 25 percent and you
know there's 32 on the offer if
five lots trade it'll buy one right or
if
you know if it's in buy order it'll work
out it'll work some bids in here here
here it'll work them all the way down a
few levels as well as you know
monitoring house trading on the offer
side basically wants to participate at
each
level now
the reason why i talk about that is
because you know i i sort of want to get
into you know big orders do have effects
on the market okay and there's different
ways that uh traders nowadays are able
to work them and if you're watching the
order book
resting liquidity the volumes are
constantly changing
right sometimes there's going to be big
orders that flash up in here okay like
here you see 228 328
um you know 170 when you just see 63
here it's constantly changing and
honestly you know trying to keep track
of it in your head
is not always the easiest thing to do
you know especially if you're trading
some of these markets you know right now
it's you know mid-march and there's all
this crazy stuff going on in the world
and the markets are are jumping around
very fast you know e-mini s ps is a very
tight market it's just a one-tick bit
offer you know but sometimes you know
crude runs into these periods where
you're looking at a 5 or 10 tick bit
offer you know wheat nasdaq don't even
get me started on that market you know
it it jumps off
the dome sometimes it just gets moved so
fast because there's just not a lot of
liquidity in there
now the order flow sequencing okay
is
basically when you have a stacked order
book exists okay
meaning
subsequent more
volume going up in the offer right
remember i explained how those algos
work right so if someone say someone has
um
you know a thousand e-minis to sell
okay it's just not going to put an
iceberg order sell a thousand e-minis at
45 20 and a half right it's gonna what
it does is it chops up the order
and it'll put some in at 20 and a half
23 quarters 21 21 and quarter 21 and a
half then it's going to hold some back
and you know in case it needs to start
hitting bids and
big orders that's how big orders
are worked in the market again you know
we all hear about the almighty iceberg
order like it's some great thing but you
know in all honesty
every order that's above probably 10
lots in some ways is often iceberg in
most markets i'll say 10 lots maybe
anything over 50 lots it tends to be
iceberg nowadays
and has been since
um you know
since you know
my goodness
you know for the last 20 years i'd say
it's been like that
and
when you have a big order right you're
going to stack the order book okay but
just looking at a a dome you can see
well yeah here it's a screenshot it's
stacked right it's 25 47 51 56 62 67 87
and this is just what's showing there's
probably more behind the the 47 the 51
the 56 the 62 the 67 the 87 but again
it's constantly changing all right and
more importantly
this stuff hasn't traded yet
okay and so that that's not going to do
you any good looking at a dome yeah the
order book is stacked but so what it has
isn't traded it doesn't mean anything
you know anyone could throw in well not
anyone but you need the margin but
you know anyone could put in a big order
sell 620 just to impact the market now
sometimes you know people think that
anytime there's a big order for size the
market's going to immediately move away
that's not always the case okay
oftentimes there's a big order
shows up in the market if there's
another big trader out there he can just
scoop that up in in one
fell swoop
now
when
you see a
stacked order book
okay
that's just a clue okay but the problem
is looking on the dome it moves too fast
for you
right
and by definition
big orders right if you know there's a
big order in here
that should hold the market down right
it should put a cap on the market right
after all you know that resting
liquidity is hitting is hidden rather
and it's like running into
an iceberg in a sense like not just an
iceberg order but you know imagine an
iceberg
ship you know imagine everyone is buying
it here but there's actually a thousand
lots offered here at 21 and a half
everyone's buying it and then he's
buying it buying it buying it and then
they can't buy anymore until they they
you know this their ship sinks
okay so
in theory right that's a theory is
big orders should hold the market at bay
and they do right i don't call it a
theory but they do that
sometimes but you really got to be
thinking about what's happening in the
market
a big order should hold the market down
up when i say big order i'm telling a
big sell order okay for in terms of um
buy orders it would be
the opposite you know it's just a big
buy order should support the market
so a big order should hold the market
down
but it isn't often times right in fact
the opposite is happening the market is
working its way through the market is
strong and what do i mean by that is you
know going back to the dome
if
here right you see the big orders right
and the market is eating its way through
these big orders at subsequent levels
right and i know that it's
a sequence of more more you know more
volume more volume more volume more
volume when i say more volume i'm
talking about the price level right
before okay so obviously the 105 is not
more than 114 but again this is just the
order book
so if you see a book
an order book and you see big size and
it trades now this is where people get
confused they see well there's 328 then
the next thing they know it's
you know
45 40 bid but maybe that 328 got pulled
right and only um
75 contracts actually traded there i
mean that's sort of the these games that
these algos plays you know if
you know if they're working an offer up
here at 45.40 and the market starts
trading up there well they just back off
and because they know they could
probably sell it at
20 and a quarter
if it's 40 bid they could also sell the
40s that way but anyway
you know keep that in mind okay because
you want to be trading in the direction
of strength
right whether it's buying strength where
the people are buying subsequent bigger
offers
right or selling strength selling
subsequent bigger bids and basically
what it comes down to is when sequencing
you're going to see
subsequent higher
volume being traded at each level
for bullish sequencing or subsequent
higher volume being sold aggressively
into passive sell passive buyers on the
bid side so it'd be like 12 55 62 80 you
know 100 150 okay that would be a
bearish sequence
a bullish sequence would be if
everything just got taken out even if it
was at these levels 25 47 51 56
62 67 87
now
you know sort of before we move on um
again you know resting liquidity can be
difficult to understand because
what you think should happen often
doesn't right
this is an order book okay
in the old don't say the old days 10
years ago people would put out training
courses okay they show you a picture of
a dome like this
41 99 73 124 102 113 110 on the bid here
so you've seen it's more on the bid than
more on the offer so they say you should
be buying this offer well
what happened here is the market sold
off
right because everyone's saying well you
got support in the market you can see it
all here in the book but what they they
fail to understand is
what is happening in the market
you have
these bids right you have these
execution algos these smart
ex you know computerized programs out
there they're working these bids in here
but the market's starting to trade down
so what they do is they they pull it out
they pull that liquidity out so
even though
this market drops from you know 36 down
to 35
it doesn't trade 124 here maybe it
trades 86 because it pulled 50 lots out
of there because it's knowing them it's
seeing the markets dropping so it's
removing its bid moving it down to 25
removing it's 25s down to 35 even
and so on right because now that they're
working to get better fills for their
customers in that direction
so
you know sort of the
it becomes like candlestick patterns
almost in the sense that yeah sometimes
the resting liquidity works sometimes it
doesn't now that's not to say that it
never works of course it does right if
you've ever watched you know um you know
a heat map right you see these resting
orders now that's a different type of
order
often times you know if you see like on
on a heat map
a line going across you know a big order
and it's been there for days well that's
probably what they call paper right
that's an order legitimate order that's
been sitting in the market it's probably
not going to get pulled but when you see
stuff like that it does have its
significance
but back to the dome in time and sales
problem is
this moves too fast here this is 9 45
and 53 seconds
this is 9 45 and 55 seconds and the
problem is everything in trades is a one
lot the average trade size i think in
the e-minis
um is just under two contracts i think
it's like one point
uh almost like one and a half because
these algos they chop them all up you
know it's even though the orders for a
thousand contracts or whatever
it chops it up into the smallest size
one lot
and you can see how it traded on the
bids you can see how it traded on the
offer in the time and sales
on the dome i mean now they got smart
domes out there which you know will
show you you know volume for a certain
period of time that you could refresh
and all that but again it's
it's one
it's just a dome just gives you people's
intentions of what
trying to do not what they're actually
doing the time it sells tells you what
they're actually doing you know somebody
that's in a trade
is committed to the market right they
have to make a decision one way or the
other at some point to get out
now what if there was a way and there is
a way to take all this information that
you're seeing on the time and sales and
put it in easy read format well that's
the footprint chart
okay
and
you know footprint charts have existed
out there for
you know 20 years or so and there's a
lot of great information out there for
traders to take advantage of
and if you know what to look for you can
see where this sequencing occurs right
there's a lot of numbers here people get
scared looking at a footprint chart but
if you know
what sequencing is in understanding it
where there's these big orders in the
market
right again
if it's bullish sequencing it would be
happening on the way up if it was
bearish sequencing it would happen on
the way down
right and here's your bearish sequencing
right here right the 28th at 142 145 164
418.
so there was a
buy order in here or buying it doesn't
necessarily have to be one order it
could be a you know a couple big orders
lumped in together around the same area
but what you have is you have someone
that was interested to buy it here again
this market this was on the 25th of
february right the market was going up
came in here there's a big buyer right
and people say well there's a big buyer
shouldn't the market go up
well
in theory yeah but what's happening is
traders are working hard selling into
this
what do you want to call it market
generated support that's happening right
here this big buyer coming into the
market
but
at this level now again it's it's not it
could be this the aggressive selling
that's taking place
um you know it could be if one big
seller you know it could be somebody
with a lot of supply
you know people that want to take
profits you know a combination of a lot
but what's happening is the market is
working
to get through that big buyer
that's potentially offering support
right here in this market
and who's winning well
the aggressive sellers are winning right
because at the end of the day
what moves the market most is the
aggressive trading uh i don't say always
moves the market is aggressive trading
because if you have a big passive
buyer or big passive seller that can
stop a move very easily but this market
is moving it's working
to fill
that passive buyer up here
and it's working hard it's stronger than
the passive buying the aggressive
selling is stronger than the passive
buying
but seeing it on a footprint chart can
be difficult because it's not easy it
takes a trained eye and you really got
to focus your attention you know maybe
people that trade on a dome um
would want to look for it on a on a
footprint chart but to be honest you
don't need to right you could have
software that does it for you so again
if you're looking at the chart you know
you're trying to figure out okay well
you're 16 37 97 you know 94 118 oh
that's not it um you know okay now we're
going down
it's just easier to have
software that would highlight it for you
you know and it's right here the 1331 75
112 231
okay
and the market
went up after it got through this big
size here there was a big offer here
someone had some supply to sell
when the market worked its way through
those levels
so
again
sequencing does exist in the market
and
the way you can see it is you need a
footprint chart or you got to train
yourself
to see it on the footprint chart
but that's difficult for a lot of people
that's why we created the indicator the
order flow sequencing indicator for
ninjatrader 8. now it runs on
ninjatrader 8 it's not on tradestation
it's not on sierra charts it's on
ninjatrader 8 because that's the
software that i use right i create these
tools
to make my trading easier that's how
order flows got started was to
make my own personal trading easier and
you know over time people would say mike
i need to see this tool i need that tool
um can you do this for us so yeah that's
why we release these indicators and
order flow sequencing is one so this is
e-mini's yesterday you can see where the
sequencing is coming in as the market is
selling off as the market is rallying
now
we on our footprint chart the order
flows trader
5.0 which we released
the 5.0 version earlier this year
it's available and
the thing is on the footprint chart
right what we have it as is just showing
you on the footprint where sequencing is
because you know traders that use a
footprint chart
tend to be
active traders right they're actually
they're monitoring the market and
they're putting what they're seeing in
context of the market
because at the end of the day even
though if you know where sequencing is
you still need to know how to apply it
which ones to take or not and that's why
we created the order flows sequencing
indicator we
which
trades you should take and you know
honestly we've got the settings they're
very simple to use very there's very few
settings you got to worry about
you have the cluster size you know five
is the default um a swing period whether
you want to be taking it at
swing highs or swing lows right that's
you would enable that
or if you just want to see it anywhere
you would just disable that we have a
sound alert
as well so you know if you want to
enable the sound alert you can
you know have it running on your
computer do your other thing and then
you know if sequencing appears you know
you get
a ding you know alert you know
sequencing or whatever
sound you want to have
we have a the trade entry signal which
i'll talk about later and the visuals
you can
choose to
have like a zone drawn out over a
certain amount of bars or if it's until
tested again you know because the market
will often come back to those levels
sometimes they will hold sometimes they
will not
and i'll just run you really quick
through you know sort of some of the
settings
now that
in the user guide we i talk about you
know different settings for different
markets and all but i just want to show
you um you know a couple of the
different charts here so this is with a
cluster size of three so it's looking
for a sequencing of three and you know a
swing filter of one so it's got to have
you know a recent high or recent low
and
some markets you would use three some
markets you would use five so markets
that aren't as volatile you know for
example like interest rates
you'd use three markers that are more
volatile you know stock indices you'd
use five
so this is buns on the 25th obviously
you had that nice move down but you can
see how it's picking you know almost
these nice turning points in the market
you know you know sometimes there's
sequencing that fails okay fine but you
know you know where you're going to be
getting out that's why we draw these
zones
um you can have them drawn until they
test again which i'll show you in a bit
this is ultra bonds
okay
so you can see it's catching the nice
major moves
but again you know there are a couple
small losses here and there but i mean
unfortunately there's nothing that's 100
in trading here's euro currency
okay you see it's picking nice turning
points here
now
zones okay i said you can have these
zones drawn out like here this is drawn
out five i like to use these zones for
you know just so i could see on on the
chart where my stop should be if it
starts trading back into those zones um
you know i want to be getting out you
can choose not to have those zones okay
so for example here this is mini dao
this is with no zones drawn out okay so
you can have it drawn out you know
five bars ten bars you can adjust that
or whatever you like or you could have
no zones this is no zones or you can
have it drawn until tested okay
and you can see here look at this came
right down to that level
here came right to that level
here it came to the level sort of spun
around here just went right through
um here just went right through this one
hasn't been tested yet here sort of came
up here and
went through but then just sort of hung
around now
there are people that love to trade
these types of levels they'll just throw
an offer right here they'll throw a bid
here
okay
with their stop just on the other side
of the zone okay so there's different
ways to trade it i like to use these
zones
for my own trading
one i know where the stop is going to be
right but
obviously
you know if a market sells off here and
i get another signal i'm not going to
still hold this short and come back up
here get out
um
these until tested zones are for people
that want to work bids and offers for
retests but again it's not where the
market always comes back to that level
and
and reverses off that level sometimes
you know the levels are fantastic you
know like here this was ultra bonds
came right through that level and shot
up um
there's e-minis and then even in the
european hours right it came right to
that level then sold off but again it's
there's different ways to trade it me i
just like to take the trades as soon as
they happen
i don't necessarily trade for the uh
retests
but if we're coming back to that level
um
i may throw a bid or an offer in you
know here's
was this gold
all right you can see it came to this
level came to that level
we got some open levels here
some small levels here a small level
here
there crude oil
okay obviously crude's been very
volatile
over the last month but you can see how
these levels
you know can give you
um some low risk entries you know if you
want to trade it that way personally i
think you know you're better off taking
the trade initially and you know for a
second trade opportunity when it comes
back to a zone
here we go this is crude oil from you
know
taking levels from the previous
session right you see it comes right to
that level comes right to this level
comes right to that level
um
mes
okay it blew right through this level
came right up to that level
these levels got right through and this
is the open one going into the weekend
now
the other thing i want to talk about one
of the settings that's important
is the trade entry signal and what the
trade entry signal does i have this on
all my indicators
is
it
confirms whether you should take the
trade or not based on what happens in
the subsequent bars where there's a
signal generated
and
you could adjust it you could enable it
you could disable it you could adjust
how many ticks markets got to move over
how many bars i use two and two and the
best way to explain it is to look on a
chart and you can see where these
circles are there's no up or down
triangle right so the conditions were
met in the sequencing but there's no
actual signal the signal is the triangle
up the triangle up the triangle up
triangle down
so it's keeping me out of these trades
here keeping me out of this short here
obviously this short kept me out of it
went down kept me out of this long
kept me out of this long which probably
would have stopped me out on this red
bar here
and this long up here so while there was
one nice trade that worked out it kept
me out of this losing trade this losing
trade this losing trade this losing
trade this losing trade
because if i was just taking any time
sequencing occurred and there was no
follow through order flow it would show
a sell signal here a sell signal here
sell signal here a buy here a buy here
and a buy here
okay so i'm fine to forgive
pass on this trade even though this
trade worked out
because it's keeping me out of there's
one
two three four five six actually seven
here this one there was a signal
here but no actual trade entry signal
here
so seven trades one of which was a
winner so five
six were losers okay so imagine you can
take out
a chunk of your losing trades when
there's no follow through order flow
so this
if you want to disable it right you take
out that check mark there and then
all those signals would show here here
here up here okay so you you
me personally i use the trade entry
signal on on pretty much everything
except for one or two very slow moving
markets where i want to see what's
happening
but
you know it's just an extra filter to
keep you out of trades that don't have
that follow-through order flow
okay so
i hope you guys found some value in this
training if you're interested in the
indicator go to orderflows.com
sequencing slash index.html the link is
below
in the comments section as well as in
the description section so you can just
click on that
and i really think it's going to help a
lot of people in their trading you know
the beauty of it is you can add it to
your normal candlestick chart right you
don't need to look at a footprint chart
right footprint charts are great but i
do understand that not everybody is
going to
use a footprint chart or not everybody
wants to use a footprint chart right
because at the end of the day you know
it's
footprint charts are great but it takes
time to get used to what you're looking
at
right and
you know some of us are older right we
go into things kicking and screaming and
it's just easier
to put the information right the trade
signals you're going to look for on a
footprint chart on a normal bar chart
okay
so
thanks for watching this video
again the overflow sequencing tool is
available
just click on the link below and i'll
see you guys on the inside take care